right now America is in danger of
lagging behind other countries in the
race to electrify vehicles Thomas
Friedman and others have talked about
this at length and they're saying a et
is the new electric technology and is an
energy technology are the new the new IT
of the next coming decades and other
companies are further along than we are
other country and other countries are
further along than we are so we have
some catching up to do but Detroit
remains a real powerhouse tremendous
amount of work on batteries and plug-in
vehicles is going on in Michigan and in
other parts in the Midwest and we think
there's still a lot of possibility for
the United States to be a leader in
plug-in vehicles
right now China is showing the signs of
becoming the leader in in plug-in
vehicle technologies they've got
demonstration programs going on in there
13 largest cities and they are moving
ahead on batteries they a chinese
company BYD became the first company to
sell a plug-in hybrid in modern times
and they're very aggressive and now
recently when President Obama went to
China they announced an agreement for a
us-china plug in a vehicle initiative
and that's a cooperative program between
the two countries and we think that
there's a lot of possibilities for
collaboration on design on components on
assembly and there's hundreds of
millions of vehicles around the world
that can be fixed by these by these two
countries and others as well as building
new vehicles
people are finally realizing that
plug-in cars are practical for them
maybe when the first hybrids came in the
car makers had to say you don't have to
plug this vehicle in began plugging in
was bad but now we've come for 10 years
where we're all accustomed to plugging
in our cell phones and we just do it
it's not a big deal and now plugging in
is good and people are understanding
that when I'm the world's first consumer
owner of a plug-in hybrid and when I
used to drive around and they saw my
people saw my car with hundred plus
miles per gallon on the side of it they
said what's that and a few years later
they'd say oh that's a plug-in hybrid
how do I get one and then a few later
years later they said well when are they
going to be available in the dealers so
there's been a progression and surveys
recently are showing that half of
Americans would like to have these cars